and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review pirates of the Kirby on
Stranger Tides oh yeah this is a great
movie for a scene in my life
spoilers spoilers the spoilers in this
review this is pirate need Jack Sparrow
and even though he wears eyeliner his
drunk as hell and he can't understand
where he's saying he's the sexiest
pirate ever and apparently no one can
recognize him that is he sneaks in as a
judge in a courtroom and everybody's
like what is the verdict of the judge
with the eyeliner golden teeth and
incredible tan no guilty
oh now the excuse me how to talk to my
teeth some old man turns out Jack
Sparrow gets captured if he comes across
captain mimosa and Jack Sparrow is like
you know we betrayed each other a
million times in these movies I know I
came to forget are we good or evil will
be all working for Disney honey eat
regex marrow it steams and goes looking
for that Fountain of Youth but luckily
he has the help of his father Keith
Richards hello I'm Keith Richards bye
but then Jack finds out that somebody is
posing it to him so jack goes to find
out who's been posing as him and it
turns out it's its old girlfriend what a
twist
what a totally non making sense twist
really nobody could figure out that a
woman is in Jack Sparrow I thought
people only fell for that and Monty
Python movies are any women here today
those barrels girlfriend knocked him out
it takes him aboard the boat to pack
beard black beards big bag bitchin boat
barbeque editor the black beard is
played by the guy from Deadwood all
right you
oh and the tribal backyard has
telepathic powers over his ship why I'm
Julie duck but it drezz objects Bill's
girlfriend has a secret little secret
I'm Blackbeard's daughter oh yes yes no
oh no oh yes I'm Johnny Depp so it turns
out Blackbeard is also looking for the
Fountain of Youth so that he won't die
there be a prophecy saying that I'm
gonna die someday so that's why me my
samba fight crew are looking for the
Fountain of Youth
you said the fight crew yes why'd you
turn into zombies so they won't die well
why don't you turn yourself into a semi
on Johnny Depp but it turns out the
prophecy says the princess is gonna kill
him his memo table because Blackbeard
put his ship in a bottle
I put a ship in a bottle once actually
no II did but I can see toy ball three
times fast 21 three times fast he's just
kidding at really Kendall toy boat toy
boat toy boat trade it's hard it's like
the only talent I have so it turns out
in order for the fun of you towards an
even tier of a mermaid oh that shouldn't
be too hard after all
mermaids are such soft delicate
creatures that only aah
holy crab these mermaids are like
werewolves a worm a Ameri we'll just
wait and see one day I'll be eating your
flesh back but in turn something to
capture one of the mermaids and the only
person who wants to be nice to her is
the clergyman yeah there's a clergyman
on Blackbeard's boat so in case if he
says he's religious that makes all the
evil things he does okay like the SS Fox
News so the clergyman it's really nice
to her it even helps her walk on land
wait a minute how can mermaids walk out
lad will you see Oliver meat has to do
is step on landed and all that since she
grows human legs
oh you're very ill knew that hey sorry
lil mermaid it turns out you didn't have
to give me your tongue after on oh you
know you look what you're doing so they
finally get to the Fountain of Youth but
it turns out that Spaniards get there at
the same time and they're like this
place is an abomination to God tear it
down
don't you want to try it to see if it
works are you telling me that our
perception of God in the 17th century
sign open or adaptive yes you're right
come on come on come on protects mailman
just to get a little bit of the valley
using these two cups one cup will give
you eternal life the false cup will take
you from you it sounds familiar with me
who did before oh yeah come on so black
bear thinks he's saving himself to kill
his daughter but when released really
himself to save his daughter ha ha this
would save me and Jasper's girlfriend is
like he was a good man even though he's
killed hundreds of people who tried to
kill his daughter his wedding
it's you crazy I'm gonna leave you on
this island yes me I do with all my
heart why did you do that so after my
mother kills Blackbeard he takes charge
of his boat Jack Sparrow gets the Black
Pearl back so really nice mermaid rouse
the clergyman Thanks and the girlfriend
is unjustifiably screwed yo ho yo ho
this story makes no sense gray but of
course this is all just built up for
Pirates of the Caribbean 5 it's under 2
hours tick I'm just kidding he'll never
be under 2 hours
it's a lot of Arabia of Johnny Depp not
making sense movies ready to fear and
loathing in las vegas this is jerry
bouncing giant get your shine I can I
have a guy over yeah Jumanji
come on OSI Java C 2003 times fast
the trick is to not see room